usual gun this isn't business as usual
and that starts now with how we're
approaching black ops for multiplayer
universe and who better to do that than
Dan bunting and Lord vonderhaar
[Applause]
[Music]
hey David what are you doing I gotta
update my twitter name to lord
vonderhaar and show me how alright thank
you everyone for coming today we are
here so excited to tell you finally
about this game that the team at
Treyarch has been working on for the
past few years and for those of you who
have not been with us for one of our
past multiplayer reveals we are going
deep today before we tell you all about
black ops 4 multiplayer which is set in
a narrative world between black ops 2
and black ops 3 we're just gonna show it
to you can I can I take this line give
my all right knock yourself out right
here is the worldwide reveal trailer for
call of duty black ops for multi player
[Applause]
alive
[Music]
- and now not in the presence of Bravo
secure
pushing on me
[Music]
every shot counts
we strike team deploy
in Vatican
I've got shooters line
marking targets
so why is it going life
heels cover
eat this
[Applause]
energy lost count of how many times you
killed me in that video so black ops 4
represents our most ambitious
multiplayer to date that delivers
grounded combat tight gunplay an
authentic military feel and of course
the fluid and responsive controls that
you know and love all routes in the most
refined tactical team experience that
we've ever delivered it it's a deeper
and more rewarding experience that will
be played for a long time to come
alright wanderer let's just get
something out of the way you guys ready
can you thrust job
can you all run
[Applause]
can you confirm we are 100% boots on the
ground
look as we know you love the fluid feel
of black ops 3 combat so the question
that we always start with is how do you
create a more grounded and tactical
experience but do it without slowing
down the player
so that's pretty easy right we didn't
stop believing in guns up so in black
ops 4 where you still move and interact
with the world in a really fast and
fluid way and you can still keep your
gun up while doing many of the other
things in the game like throwing
grenades and using equipment activating
scorestreaks and mantling and what's
better than doing all of those things
while still being able to fire your gun
and it's doing this while firing your
gun ruin returns and this time he
brought his special issue equipment the
grapple gun that only he can equip and
create a class so ruin is a specialist
with those unique ability to close the
gaps and get to the enemy faster and the
combos that you can pull off when you
grapple to grab slam have been making
the highlight reel inside the studio and
we can't wait to see just what you do
with this
so specialists are back both new and
some familiar but totally reimagine
because each specialist brings special
issue equipment that delivers unique
capabilities to your team to reinforce
the tactical gameplay without slowing
down the player and you'll hear about
many of them throughout the discussion
but you would be fooling yourself if you
thought that they were the main
characters of this show that's right
because black ops is and always has been
first and foremost about weapons and the
gameplay around it it's no different
with black ops 4 however with black ops
where we've made more improvements to
gun systems then literally the entirety
of black ops 1 2 & 3 combined this just
show is how serious we are about weapon
systems at Treyarch we've designed each
weapon as though it's a character in and
of itself which means that we a pata pay
attention to every single detail hot
barrels are gonna ooze smoke muzzle
flashes are gonna burst and light up the
room bullet impacts are massive and they
connect the player with the game world
around them and weapons for the first
time have real 3d tracers which both
look and feeling
credibly awesome but they also serve a
gameplay purpose because they let you
know where the gunfire is coming from
and animations have been overhauled to
make that feel that you know and love
that much more responsive bullets will
actually deplete as you expend the
magazine but that's just the start this
is a small example of the details that
we pay attention to our weapons on the
design front the black ops 4 is gonna
break with tradition by giving each
weapon its own set of attachments now in
the past attachment sets were shared
across weapon classes but this is
important to us because unique
attachments are all about making the
gameplay of weapons stay and mate makes
what makes me each weapon stand out from
each other we're also bringing a new
category of attachment this game it's
called operator mods operator mods are
the ultimate expression of a guns
profile it's going to expand its
capabilities and ways to go beyond that
core functionality you're gonna see here
the titan LMG laying down some heavy
heavy suppression fire that suppressive
effect is only capable through its
operator mod it's gonna distort and
disorient the enemy on the other side of
it now I'm excited to say that weapons
are further defined by another first in
franchise history today I'm here to tell
you black ops 4 will be the first game
in our history to use a true predictive
recoil pattern system this allows you to
constantly make micro adjustments while
aiming and shooting this means that the
gameplay of each weapon is learn about
there's a path to mastery that is
rewarding for new players and veterans
alike this is by far our biggest
investment in the weapons platform in
combat systems that we've made to give
you the most rewarding and visceral
experience by pushing the
state-of-the-art on weapons visuals
animations and sound effects weapons and
health are two sides of the same coin
and you can't change one without
affecting the other and black ops 4 adds
some tactical depth through a change in
the healing mechanic healing is no
longer automatic now players manually
trigger their healing process with a
dedicated button and that becomes
essential to your gameplay loop as
reloading the weapon after a firefight
and we like this change because it
creates a tactical decision point that
simply didn't exist before so you can
disengage from combat and heal up or you
can rush a nonce
affecting opponent who may be healing
herself and these changes create a more
tactical pace to the game where instead
of simply losing to the person who
shoots first you can actually survive a
gunfight with smart maneuvering and this
means you spend more time in the part of
the game that's the most fun which is
the combat so aggressive players still
feel rewarded for being aggressive and
tactical players can actually choose
when to disengage and look for a better
opportunity to strike our journey into
the health mechanics has evolved it
doesn't end just here let me introduce
you to crash and crash is a medic and
this means when his ability is ready to
use
he can actually restore and give bonus
health to players for a limited time and
crash is just more than a medic he also
distributes a salt pack which resupplies
team and no doubt the folks at home are
already breaking down that MP trailer
and they've already figured out what
this one's lying so we've taken a
completely fresh look at the health
mechanics of a black ops multiplayer
game to insert tactical decisions and
some much-needed pacing into that
gameplay loop so so far we've talked
about some really fundamental building
blocks of what multiplayer and what
makes it awesome you got movement
weapons health systems we're gonna take
it up a level to situational awareness
situational awareness covers the gamut
of what you see in here in the game from
the mini-map to the sounds that your
footsteps make on different surfaces
we've experimented with all sorts of
modifiers that have impacted this over
the years but in black ops 4 we embrace
situational awareness is a fundamental
feature to the game we're introducing a
new system called the fog of war and
only the parts around the mini around
the play on the mini-map the fog of war
reveals a radius around the player and
hasn't hurt teammates as you'd expect
and me players are gonna reveal their
positions when firing a weapon unless
they're suppressed and many of your
favorite score streaks like UAVs
encounter unities are still gonna do
what you expect them to do but what the
fog of war does it creates more
opportunities for teammates to
communicate and work together for the
win now I'm going to introduce you to
another new specialist his name is recon
recon is an expert in situational
awareness his special issue equipment is
called the sensor Dart when he shoots
the sensor dart into the world it clears
a large radius
around it that both he and his teammates
can see and it helped you to locate
enemies he also has vision pulse which
makes a return from black ops 3 but this
time around it's a little bit different
the whole team gets the benefit of it
so with effective usage these mechanics
together can be a clutch way to snag
victory from the jaws of defeat
situational awareness is as important to
the gameplay loop as weapons health and
movement and as with the other
fundamentals were giving you the players
access to these top tools to control
your own gameplay loop the flow of
combat is how movement and weapons and
health and situational awareness all
come together in the head-to-head
gameplay spawning pathing level design
all of these things impact that flow you
might remember Sarah she has attacked
deploy and this is a team wide spawn
beacon that allows Seraph to command
offensive control over that flow of
combat for a period of time and this is
torque torque is the master of
disrupting that flow because he can lay
down razor wire and create deployable
and improvised cover with his barricade
and one last one over the years we've
experimented with the idea of
area-denial in various ways and in black
ops 4 it's time to stop playing around
fire break makes his return and makes
area-denial a part of that gameplay loop
his special issue geared the reactor
core allows him to do just that and
firebreak can even trade his own health
to extend the clock on that time so
we've combined the best designs and how
level spawning and flow control work
together to influence the gameplay loop
and then we place those tools not in our
hands but indeed the hands of you
through the specialists
and the story of black ops 4 is not one
of a single game and development but
rather the combined journey of the
entire last decade of black ops and you
the community have been with us every
step of that way every game that we make
is an opportunity for us to do better to
continue the dialogue that we have with
you and you know that we listen you
expect that commitment from us and this
is why we do what we do so I think we've
covered all the details we've pretty
much given away the secret recipe to our
multiplayer experience what I miss just
one little thing just want to tease for
our competitive community and that is
the return of league play league play is
a fan favorite and we've combined the
very best parts of it and we're going to
deliver it for all the players of black
ops 4 as Mark mentioned in his opening
remarks we're doing some things a little
bit different in this year including how
we tell stories in each mode throughout
the game now we're delivering more
narrative and character depth and
multiplayer than ever before and we're
also going to give new and returning
players the ability to learn and master
each of these specialists and solo
missions these missions feature a series
of fun and fast-paced trials that give a
hands-on introduction to the new and
returning specialists while exploring
the stories behind their identities and
their backgrounds inside of a black ops
scenario now with each game that black
ops players have spent more and more
time in multiplayer and it's important
to us that we go bigger on that
experience and expand the narrative
universe around it here is just a
glimpse into that universe not bad not
bad yourself
no one gives a [ __ ] about you
number
an asset
the pawn and someone else's game
they've been manipulating you
watching you
exploiting you
so here's the deal alone you can put up
a fight but together you can start a war
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]